[音楽]
こんにちははじめまして開け先と言います高校3年生です
突然ですがみなさん
今
これからやりたいことそして関心を持っていることは何ですかと聞かれて答えることが
できますか
またその答えを周りの人に声に出して伝えることは出来ますか
私が高校2年生の時
はっきりとした目標や夢もなかった私を
大きく変えてくれた出来事がありました
今日はその時感じたことを皆様にお話ししようと思います
今私は私が変わったと言いました
どう変わったのかというと
将来の事なんてぼんやりとしか考えていなかった私が
ある物事に完成持つようになり
そこに感心を持っているということを自覚するようになったということです
その出来事は私にとってとても意味のある出来事でしたが
きっかけは些細なことでした
あることを境に自分の意識が変わるというのは誰にでもいつでも起こりうることだと
思うんです
その出来事を通して私は関心がを持つことの大切さを学んだんですが
人はどうやって関心を持つようになるのだろう
皆さんは考えたことがありますか
私はありませんでした
なので少し考えてみました
ご覧ください
ちょっと a を書いたんですけど
ゆいな上に
小さな島が一つ
あります
その島の周りを多数の大陸が囲んでいてその大陸と一つの島は1本の橋でつながって
いるのを想像してください
この大陸っていうのは人々が持つ関心ごとを表しています
手を挙げてみると
経済とか
教育とか
国際関係とか
こうやって言葉で言い尽くすこともできないほど多くの本や分野が私たちの周りにあり
それぞれが進歩しているので私はこれらを大陸とたとえました
何事にも関心が無い人はこの小さな島の真ん中にいます
この人が何かに関心を持った時
自分で橋を見つけて大陸に渡ることができる
その流れを関心を持つまでの過程だと考えてください
島の上にいる人は
橋を渡ろうとしません
あるいは橋を見つけることができないから
大陸に渡ることができません
その原因として
端を探すこと
足を渡ること
つまり自分が何に関心を持っているのか
何を本当にやりたいことなのかということを見つける
確かめるその行為を面倒くさいとかそういう行為をすることに対しての周りの人の目が
気になるとかそういうことが挙げられると思います
だけど
周りの人の勧誘とか
偶然起こった出来事など
ほんの少しのきっかけで
人は端を見つけ渡ることができるんだと思います
足を見つけたらあとは自分で歩いていたり
マーリンとに押されたりしながら橋を渡りきる
こんな感じだと思います
要は
端を見つけるそしてその橋を一方
わたるそれが大事なんだと思います
きっかけさえあれば誰だって自分が何に関心を持っているのかがわかるときがくるん
です
ではここで私が変わることができた
発しを渡ることができた出来事について話したいと思います
ある日私の学校の先生が通るツアーに誘ってくださいました
そのツアーの名前は日々がは es 技術ああ
いいときませんよねえっ
それは高校生を対象としたもので岐阜県にある
揖斐川という川の上流から下流まではバスで降り
その流域の
自然や地域の恵みに触れながらその地域を取り巻く環境問題
社会問題について考えていこうといった内容のものでした
これを見てください
食べ物です
おいしそうだと思いませんか少し紹介します
左上にあるのがその揖斐川の流域で採れる山菜を使ったお弁当
そしてその横とその下にあるのかその地域で採れた
卵や野菜などをふんだんに使った美味しいご飯でした
そして一番伝えたいのが右のしたです
これは木有権者ないんですけど三重の桑名市で採れた
ハマグリのご飯です
私はハマグリをそんなに食べたことがないのでしかも採れたてのハマグリを食べさせて
くれたんですけどそれが彫ったをに美味しくて
まず私がツアーに誘われたときはこれを先生に見せられました
そんな環境のこととか全然考えたこともなかった私はこれを見てこのツアーに行きたい
と思って参加することにしました
これのために参加したも同然だったんです
だけどこのツアーは私の想像を遥かに超えていました
現地の人の環境問題に対する
猪狩
楽しみ
不安
そして感謝の気持ち
生の声
私が直接聞くことそして実際にツアーに参加することで現場を見る
そしてこれらの食べ物を通して
など
五感を持ってしてその地域の問題について学ばさっちさせていただきました
映像などではなくて実際に人から直接お話し機を聞くことによってこんなにもリアルに
伝わるんだなぁと感じました
そのツアーは私たち参加した高校生が
この後現場を見て
どう思ったのか
そしてこの問題を解決するために私たちは何をすればいいのかといった意見を交換する
機会がたくさんありました
そこで私はたくさんたくさん考え悩みました
どうすれば現地の人が
誰も苦しむことがなく過ごすことができるのか
誰かの利益を取れば一方で誰かが悲しむ
そんな答えなんてない難しい問題でした
私の中で答えを出すことはできませんでした
本当に悔しかったです
そこの人たちが
何年も何十年もこの問題に悩まされ苦しみ続けていたのかと考えるととても胸が痛かっ
たんです
でも
その地域の人やツアーの参加ささぁ主催者のみなさんは私たち高校生にこう言いました
他の地域に住んでいる子達が
私たちの地域の問題についてこんなにも真剣に悩んでくれている
それだけで私たちは本当にうれしいよと
ありがとう等
言われました
ありがとうなんて
普段
何気ない時でも言っているのに私はその時にありがとうが本当に重く感じました
そこで私はツアーの人たちを見て
ツアーの3カ所企画した人たちを見て
こんなに人の
人に感謝されることをするって本当に素晴らしいことだなとそのときに感じました
そこでふと思ったんです
私もツアーの企画した皆さんのように
人のためになる行動がしたいのかもしれないなと
その時私は席ほど紹介しました橋を見つけたんだと思います
先生の何気ない一言で参加が決まったこのツアーは私が橋を見つけ橋を渡り出す一方の
きっかけを与えてくれたんです
しばらくして
esd という持続可能な社会を作ろうという活動をしている人たちが集う
さあ活動報告会に参加させていただきました
そこで私は私にもっと地域を与えてくれた女の子に会いました
その本国会では大人たちが自分が行っている活動を紹介している中
女の子はその日のかその日の感想として
こんなことを述べました
私たち高校生は
世のため人のために活動するための活力が有り余っているんです
だけど今の世の中は高校生があまり活動しているようには見えない
それはなぜだと思いますか
それは
私たちが活動する場がないからだと私は考えます
大人のみなさんわたしたちが活躍できる場を作ってください
衝撃を受けました
同じ高校生だったんです
なのに
こんなにも堂々と自分が思ったことを言い
大人たちに余裕要求することができるなんて
私とは全然違うなぁと感じると同時に私もやらなければならないという強い使命感を
感じました
私を何か形に表せないといけない
何か行動で示さなければいけない
こんなに自分が何かをしようと思ったことはありませんでした
彼女もその印象的な言葉が私を変えたんです
こうやって私は
彼女と同じように
人のため社会のためみんなを元気づけるような活動がしたいということを認識しました
だけど
後で考えました
私はそうやって私のやりたいことを見つけた
足も渡りきったと思いますだけど今私は実際に何もしていません
それって本当に自分が一生をかけてやりたいことを見つけたことになるのか
本当は何も変わっていないんじゃないか
だけど
間違いなくこれらの経験は私を支えてくれたんですよ
そこで私はこう考えることにしました
何かに対して関心を持ったということに対する自覚は
私たちがこれからそれに向けて行動するための準備であるということ
行動をする原点というのはその物事に関心を持つということにあるということ
自分が関心を持っているということに対する自覚はそれと同じことに感心を持っている
人と出会いを
出会いのきっかけを増やします
同じことに感心を持っている人が集まれば
私が参加したツアーのように一つのことをみんなで成し得ることができます
それは本当に些細なことかもしれません
もしかしたら世界を変えちゃうような大きなことかもしれません
だけどいずれにせよそれは私たちに大きな影響を与えてくれるものとなり
私たちを大いに成長させてくれるものとなるでしょ
人生は一度しかありません
やりたいことを決めて
それに向かって努力しやる
の人生を送りたいと思いませんか
なんとなく勉強してなんとなく大学に入ったりなんとなく就職したりなんとなく生活し
ていくよりも自分が一生をかけてやりたいと思えることをやる
そんな人し充実した人生を送りたい
私は今高校3年生で事件性です
だから受験に向かって
一生懸命覚えたりすることが多い面白くない勉強をしています
だけどこれらの高経験を通じて私は本気でやりたいことをやるということの大切さを
学びました
だから自分が本当にやりたいことは何かをきちんと
見定め
はっきりとして
その目標のために今の受験勉強を頑張ろうというモチベーションになりました
私は最初
皆さんに自分がやりたいことを人に言えますか
口に出して
はっきりと言えますかと聞きました
人に伝えるのはすごく難しいこと
人と自分の考え方は違います
自分が自信を持って思っていることを人に伝えて
拒否された時受け入れてもらえなかった時の辛さは誰にでも想像できるでしょ
だからこそ人に伝えられたのならばそれは本当に自分がやりたいことだと思うんです
私は
今までのこのこいこい高2の時の経験を通じてそれを見つけることができました
だから言うことができます
私は
人の笑顔が好きです
ありがとうっていう人の言葉が大好きです
自分が辛い思いをしてでも自分の木時間を削って知ってでも人のために行った活動が
他人にとって
少しでも嬉しくなったり幸せになったり
助かったり
不快に思わなくなったりする
そんな活動を自分への見返りなしにやっていけるような人間になりたいです
だから
頑張って今受験勉強して
大学生になったりしたらボランティア活動を積極的にして仲間を増やしていきたいなと
思っています
ここで言ったからに本当になるしかありません
人生における大きな目標をもっと
人は見る世界が変わります
タイミングはきっと人それぞれです
私は後任の時でした
皆さんの中にもきっとあると思います
もしない人はこの辺で一度立ち止まって自分と深く
自分の事を深く見つめ直してみませんか
[拍手]